- "To All The Boys I Loved
Before" blew up in 2018.
- Yeah.
- So how pumped are you for the sequel?
- I'm so stoked, it's like,
holding that secret in
that we were going to
make a second and a third
was the hardest thing
ever, but I'm so excited
and if you're a fan of "To All The Boys"
and you watched the first one,
I know that you're going
to love the second.
- That's awesome.
- And it's a really
wonderful, like you continue
to see her journey as
a young high schooler
trying to figure out
love and kind of balance
these new relationships,
so it's really, really fun.
I loved it.
- So the very first movie
you were in, what was it?
'Cause I'm super jealous, they don't know.
- Oh. The very first movie I
was in was "X-Men: Apocalypse"
back a little while ago.
(crowd cheering)
- [Kelly] That was your first movie.
- [Lana] Yeah.
- Like usually, peoples'
first movie is like,
no one's heard of it.
(laughs)
That's X-Men.
- It was like being just
thrown into the deep end.
It was like sink or swim, right?
You're like "This is
gonna make or break me,
I might never work again."
But it was so amazing
and I was auditioning
as a second-semester
senior in high school.
I knew I was in the running for it
and then I got a call from my
agents in the middle of class.
And you're not supposed to have your phone
but I was like, "Yo".
'Cause if it's your
agent calling you pick up
no matter what, right?
- I don't, but go ahead.
(crowd laughing)
- Well, that's good.
- He's bothered.
(laughs)
- Right, right, right.
And they were like, are you around anyone?
Can we tell you some news?
And I was like, "I'm around
everyone that I know".
So I ended up walking out of school
and I stood underneath
the great American flag.
They told me that I had
booked it but that I couldn't
tell anyone until the
press release came out.
So then I had to go back to freakin' class
being like,
- And not freak out.
- "Oh my god, oh my god."
Yeah it was crazy.
- That's an amazing first job.
- Thank you.
(cheering)
- I mean that's, that's killer.
- She's booking major
movies in high school
and I'm sweeping hair.
(laughter)
- I was selling vacuums, so..
- You know,
- You know, life.
- You gotta do what you gotta do.
So we're celebrating
"All the Feels February"
'cause it's Valentine's Day,
so you have anybody special?
- I do, my boyfriend, Anthony,
the love of my life, yes.
I don't know what we're gonna do.
We're probably just gonna like,
stay at home and just eat,
like we always do.
- [Kelly] That's the best date ever.
Oh y'all are adorable.
- [Lana] Oh, that's us.
- [Kelly] Look at him in that hat, okay.
- [Lana] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh, look at this one.
- [Lana] That's my puppy Emmy.
- Emmy's adorable.
I love your man but I love him more.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
Or her, Emmy's a girl, right?
- Yeah.
- Yes, yes, yes, beauti-, how old?
- We just celebrated her
one year, one years old
and one year being with us,
'cause we got her at like five weeks.
She knows, she knows that
it's, that it's her one year
because we woke up, and I'm a little sick,
so Anthony went and took
her out on her morning walk
and she pooped in the shape of a heart.
(crowd laughing)
Now, I would like to say
that I have a picture
of the said poop.
- That's impressive.
(laughter)
- And I can show it to you.
- I feel challenged.
(crowd laughing)
- I want you to know if you feel like,
not the vibe, please look
away , but we have a photo.
- You have a photo of the heart poop.
- Of the heart poop.
- Okay, if you wanna look
at the heart poop, go ahead,
if you don't, you know.
I wanna look at the heart poop.
(crowd laughing, applauding)
- That's actually very impressive.
- Happy Valentine's Day, you guys.
- I mean, the only thing better is if she
just sat behind it and
was like, like after.
So speaking of loved one's though,
you just went on a big family trip, right?
- I did.
- Yeah.
- So I'm adopted from Vietnam and
my family and I have not
been able to go back yet
since I was adopted when I was a baby.
So, just recently, we went back to Vietnam
and we found the
orphanage where my parents
got my brother and I and
we were able to go inside.
The paint hasn't changed,
the curtains haven't changed.
I was able to see where I
spent like the first, my first
couple of months on Earth as a baby.
Being there with my family,
it was like full complete circle.
I've never felt so just still,
and dropped-in and whole.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It was amazing, so yeah..
- Oh you are gonna Oprah me right now.
Wow, that was really, oh my gosh,
I'm like, I'm gonna cry right now.
- It was the best trip of my life
and I'm so happy that I was
able to finally do that,
'cause I've been wanting to do that.
- Randomly enough, literally,
Vietnam is the first place
my little girl ever went outside America.
- Really?
- I did an event there, like years,
and it was right when River,
my little five year old,
- [Lana] Yeah.
- She was born, it was
the first place ever,
she was like three months old.
- Did she like it?
- Well, who knows?
- Sebastian, do you do any family trips?
Y'all big on that?
- Yeah no, we didn't go to Vietnam.
- No, no. Like any family trips?
- No we go to the zoo,
we went to the LA Zoo.
- [Lana] Nice.
- I love the zoo!
- That's about as far as we got.
But that's very bold to take a child
on a, that long of a
flight at three months.
- I'll tell you what, I was terrified
'cause you didn't want all
those people to hate you.
But like, she didn't cry once.
- You know what I do,
- She was the best.
- That's amazing.
- You know what I do, which
I think is a nice touch?
I take a kid on a plane, I go around,
I pass out chocolates to everybody.
- [Kelly] Like money.
- [Lana] It's like bribery.
- Yeah, so just in case the kid does cry,
people got a little sweet.
- I know and it sucks though
because they look at you,
and they're like, "Can you do something?"
Like, do you think I
like what's happening?
- Yeah. Do you think I want this?
- Do you think I was
like, boy I hope my baby
loses it on the plane
and everyone hates me.
You know, like what
are you supposed to do?
Anyway, Vietnam is a beautiful country,
- Yes, yes.
- that was what I was trying to get to.
- Yes. (laughter)